uh dark matter matter having to do
something with the extinction events the
extinction of the
dinosaurs um which is kind of a
fascinating presentation of how
everything is connected so I guess the
disturbances
from the dark matter they create
gravitational disturbances in the OR
Cloud at the edge of our solar system
and then that increases the rate of
asteroids hitting Earth so I want to be
really clear this was a speculative
Theory mhm I love it though I mean and I
liked it too and um and we still don't
know for sure but we can what we liked
about it so let me take a step back so
we usually assume that dark matter is
what we being physicists that just one
thing it's just basically non
interacting in on aside from gravity or
very weakly interacting matter um but
again we have to get outside this
mindset of just humans and ask what else
could be there and so what we suggested
is that there's a fraction of dark
matter not all the dark matter but some
of the Dark Matter maybe it has
interactions of its own just the same
way in in our universe we have lots of
different types of matter we have nuclei
we have electrons we have M we have
forces um we have lots of it's it's not
a simple model the standard model but
but it does have some basic ingredients
so maybe Dark Matter also has some
interesting
um structure to it so maybe there's some
small fraction and the interesting thing
is that if some of the Dark Matter does
radiate and you know I like to call it
dark light because it's light that we
don't see but Dark Matter would see it
could radiate that and then it could
perhaps collapse into a disc the same
way ordinary matter collapsed in into
the Milky Way disc so it's not all the
dark matter it's a fraction but it could
conceivably be a very thin disc of Dark
Matter thin cond Den disc of dark matter
and so then the question is do these
exist and people have done studies now
to think about whether they can find
them I mean it's an interesting Target
it's something you can measure by
measuring the positions and velocities
of stars you can find out what the
structure of the of the Milky Way is um
but the fun proposal was that the solar
system orbits around the Galaxy and as
it does so it goes a little bit up and
down kind of like horses on a Carousel
and the suggestion was every time it
goes through you have an enhanced
probability that you would dislodge
something from the edge of the solar
system and something called the or Cloud
so the idea was that at those times
you're more likely to have these
cataclysmic events such as the amazing
one that actually caused the last
Extinction that we know of for sure it
wasn't so amazing for the dinosaurs or
for two-thirds of the species on the
planet yeah but it gets amazing for
humans it wouldn't be what really is
amazing I mean I I do I mean I talk
about this in dark matter the dinosaurs
I it's just an amazing scientific story
because it really is one of the real
stories that combine together different
fields of science geologists at the time
or you know people thought that things
happened slowly and this would be a
cataclysmic event and also I have to say
you know if you if you think about it it
sounds like a story like a 5-year-old
would make up maybe the dinosaurs were
killed by some big rock that came and
hit the Earth but then there really was
a scientific story behind it and that's
also why I like the dark disc because
there's a scientific story behind it so
as farfetched as it might sound you can
actually go and look for the
experimental consequences or the
observational consequences to test
whether it's true I wish you could know
like high resolution details of where
that asteroid came from like where in
the OR Cloud why it happened is it in
fact because of dark matter it's like
the full tracing back to the origin of
the universe CU it humans seem to be
somewhat special but just it seems like
so many fascinating events at all scales
at all scales of physics had to happen
for so I'm really really glad you
mentioned that because actually that was
one of the main points of my book dark
matter in the dinosaurs one of the
reasons I wrote it was because I really
think we are abusing the planet we're
changing the planet way too quickly and
just like anything else when you alter
things it's good to think about the
history of what it took to get here and
it and as you point out it took many
operations on many different scales you
know we had to have the formation of of
structure the formation of galaxies the
formation of the solar system the
formation of our planet the formation of
humans I mean there's so many steps that
go into this and humans in some part
were the result of the fact that this
big object hit the earth made the
dinosaurs go extinct and mammals
developed I mean it is an incredible
story
and yes something else might come of it
but it won't be us if we mess with it
too much but it is an a grand scale
Earth is a pretty resilient
system